>> JOINING US NOW BACK IN KABUL
IS CNN CHIEF INTERNATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT CLARISSA WARD.
IT IS GOOD TO SEE YOU IN KABUL.
TELL US WHAT THINGS ARE LIKE
ALMOST A YEAR LATER.
>> Reporter: WELL, BRIANNA, IT'S
REALLY GOOD TO BE BACK HERE.
I THINK YOU CAN PROBABLY SEE
BEHIND ME WE ARE AT A MARKET.
THERE IS A SENSE OF NORMALCY ON
THE STREETS OF THE CITY.
THERE IS NOT THE SAME SORT OF --
OR ANYTHING APPROACHING THE
LEVELS OF CHAOS AND VIOLENCE
THAT WE SAW PLAYING OUT DURING
THOSE HEART-WRENCHING SCENES
LAST YEAR, BUT THE CHANGE HAS
ALSO BROUGHT ABOUT A REAL
DECREASE IN THE STANDARD OF
LIVING HERE AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE NOW FIGHTING TO PUT FOOD ON
THE TABLE.
THE U.N. SAYS THAT NEARLY HALF
THE COUNTRY IS IN A STATE OF
ACUTE HUNGER.
THE INTERNATIONAL RESCUE
COMMITTEE SAYS BY THE SECOND
HALF OF THIS YEAR THEY
BELIEVE -- WELL, WE ARE NOW IN
THAT SECOND HALF OF THIS YEAR --
MORE THAN 90% OF PEOPLE WILL BE
LIVING BELOW THE POVERTY LINE
AND THAT'S FOR A WHOLE PLETHORA
OF REASONS, PARTLY BECAUSE OF
SANCTIONS AND THE FREEZING OF
AFGHANISTAN'S FEDERAL RESERVES
AFTER THE TALIBAN TOOK POWER,
PARTLY BECAUSE OF THE FOOD
PRICES, PARTLY BECAUSE OF
INFLATION, BUT WHAT YOU SEE WHEN
YOU GO AROUND -- AND I JUST WANT
TO SHOW YOU A LITTLE BIT SEEING
AS WE'RE HERE IN THIS MARKET --
YOU CAN SEE THERE IS FOOD.
THERE IS FOOD THAT YOU CAN BUY,
THE MARKET STALLS ARE FULL, BUT
THE CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE
BEEN HAVING WITH VENDORS MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT FOR THE VAST MAJORITY
OF PEOPLE IT'S BECOME
UNAFFORDABLE, THIS FOOD.
SO FLOUR I WAS TOLD BY THESE
VENDORS HAS DOUBLED IN PRICE,
COOKING OIL WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY
ONE OF THE BIGGEST NECESSITIES
HAS MORE THAN DOUBLED IN PRICE.
AND THAT'S NOT EVEN BEFORE,
BRIANNA, YOU START TALKING ABOUT
THE VERY REAL CHANGES AND THE
IMPACT THAT THEY HAVE HAD AS THE
TALIBAN HAS GRADUALLY BECOME
FIRMER IN IMPLEMENTING ITS
VISION OR VERSION OF SHARIA LAW.
>> I'M STRUCK BY HOW DIFFERENT
IT LOOKS FROM ONE YEAR AGO.
HOW DIFFERENT FRANKLY YOU LOOK
FROM ONE YEAR AGO.
DRESSED A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY
THAN THE DAY AFTER THE TALIBAN
REGAINED POWER.
THE STREETS ARE BUSTLING WITH
MEN AND WOMEN BEHIND YOU AND I
ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTAND THE
ECONOMIC CHALLENGES THEY'RE
FACING.
ALSO I DON'T SEE ANY HUGE ARMED
PRESENCE AROUND YOU, LIKE THERE
ALMOST CERTAINLY WAS ONE YEAR
AGO.
TALK TO US MORE ABOUT ALL OF
THAT.
>> Reporter: YEAH, SO THE
TALIBAN IS REALLY TRYING TO HAVE
A LIGHTER FOOTPRINT, AT LEAST
VISIBLY ON THE STREETS.
YOU DO STILL SEE THEM.
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE FILMED
ANYMORE, IT'S NOT LIKE THE
INITIAL DAYS WHERE THERE WAS
THIS SENSE OF JUBILATION AND
VICTORY.
NOW YOU HAVE TO GET A LOT OF
PERMISSION, IT'S AN ONEROUS TASK
TO GO THROUGH THE PROCESS TO BE
ABLE TO REPORT HERE AND THERE
HAS BEEN CERTAINLY A SORT OF
STRANGLING OF THE LOCAL MEDIA.
YOU DO SEE WOMEN, AS YOU CAN
SEE, ON THE STREETS, YOU ALSO
SEE THAT I AM DRESSED IN A LESS
CONSERVATIVE FASHION THAN I WAS
BEFORE.
I WANT TO STRESS THE TALIBAN HAS
PASSED A RULING THAT WOMEN ARE
SUPPOSED TO WEAR NOT JUST A FULL
HIJAB, A FULL HEAD COVERING BUT
THE PIECE THAT COMPLETELY COVERS
THE FACE, MOST WOMEN WEAR THE
BURQA.
MANY WOMEN IN KABUL ARE LIKE
THANKS BUT NO THANKS
ESSENTIALLY.
THEY'RE CONTINUING TO DRESS HOW
THEY USED TO DRESS.
IT SEEMS FOR THE MOMENT THE
TALIBAN DOESN'T HAVE A VESTED
INTEREST IN TRYING TO CRACK DOWN
ON THAT AND IN TRYING TO
RESURRECT THE MOST NOTORIOUS
VICE AND VIRTUE POLICE AS THEY
BECAME KNOWN.
SO THERE IS THAT SENSE THAT
PERHAPS THERE'S A SLIGHTLY
LIGHTER TOUCH THAN THERE HAD
BEEN CERTAINLY IN THE 1990s, BUT
I WANT TO STRESS, JOHN AND
BRIANNA, THAT BENEATH THE
SURFACE WE DO NOT SEE ANY REAL
MEANINGFUL CHANGES IN THE
TALIBAN'S IDEOLOGY OR IN ITS
IDEAS OF HOW BEST TO GOVERN.
SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT SEEING
WOMEN ON THE STREETS, WHERE
WE'RE NOT SEEING WOMEN ANYMORE
IS IN THEIR PLACES OF PREVIOUS
EMPLOYMENT.
WOMEN ARE STILL ALLOWED TO WORK
IN THE HEALTH CARE SECTOR, IT'S
A NECESSITY, AND IN SOME
HUMANITARIAN ROLES AS WELL AS
TEACHERS, EDUCATION, BUT WOMEN
WHO WERE WORKING IN BUSINESS,
WOMEN WHO WERE WORKING AS
MINISTERS AND IN MINISTRIES HAVE
ALSO BEEN TOLD IN ADDITION TO
ALL GIRLS ABOVE THE AGE OF 12
THAT INSTEAD OF GOING TO SCHOOL
AND INSTEAD OF GOING TO WORK
THEY MUST NOW STAY HOME.
THE TALIBAN SAYS THAT THIS IS
JUST UNTIL THE RIGHT OR CORRECT
ISLAMIC ENVIRONMENT CAN BE
CREATED, BUT THIS IS NOW MANY,
MANY MONTHS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
HEARING THIS AND THEY HAVE BEEN
PRESSED OVER AND OVER AGAIN NOT
JUST BY WESTERN JOURNALISTS BUT
BY ISLAMIC SCHOLARS FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD AND BY MUSLIM
COUNTRIES AS TO WHAT THE HOLDUP
IS AND WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
WHAT ARE THESE SPECIFIC
CONDITIONS THAT NEED TO BE
REACHED IN ORDER FOR GIRLS TO
RETURN TO SCHOOL, IN ORDER FOR
WOMEN TO BE EMBRACED IN THE
WORKPLACE AGAIN AND AGAIN.
AND WHAT WE'RE HEARING FROM THE
TALIBAN IS KIND OF OBFUSCATION
ON THIS POINT.
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE DRAWN INTO
THE DETAILS AS TO THE CONDITIONS
THEMSELVES WHICH MAKES MANY
PEOPLE HERE VERY NERVOUS THAT
THERE IS NO REAL PLAN, IN FACT,
TO TRY TO REINTEGRATE WOMEN INTO
THIS SOCIETY.
JOHN, BRIANNA.
>> AND WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR
THE FUTURE OF GIRLS THERE?
THERE'S ACTUALLY A LITTLE GIRL,
CLARISSA, WHO HAS BEEN DARTING
IN AND OUT AT TIMES THROUGH THE
BACK OF YOUR LIVE SHOT THERE WHO
WE CAN SEE WHO LOOKS PROBABLY --
SHE WAS THERE BEFORE, BUT SHE'S
PROBABLY AROUND 10 OR SOUTH OF
10.
HOW IN THE LAST YEAR HAS HER
FUTURE CHANGED AND IF YOU COULD
SPEAK TO THAT FOR KABUL, BUT
ALSO IN RURAL AREAS AS WELL.
>> Reporter: SO THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT POINT THAT YOU BRING
UP, BRIANNA, BECAUSE WHAT YOU
SEE AND FEEL IN KABUL IS NOT THE
SAME AS WHAT YOU'RE SEEING AND
FEELING IN RURAL AREAS WHERE
WOMEN'S EDUCATION WAS NEVER A
PRIORITY, WHERE GIRLS WERE OFTEN
MARRIED OFF AT A VERY YOUNG AGE
AND WHERE THE SOCIETY IS
GENERALLY SPEAKING MUCH MORE
CONSERVATIVE AND MUCH MORE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE TALIBAN.
SO WHAT YOU HEAR IN RURAL AREAS
IS THAT PEOPLE ARE JUST
DELIGHTED THAT THE AMERICANS
LEFT, THAT THE WAR HAS
ESSENTIALLY CALMED DOWN, THAT
THERE HAS BEEN A RETURN TO
RELATIVE PEACE AND QUIET AND
THEY'RE NOT FOCUSED ON THESE
SORT OF MORE INTERESTING OR MORE
COMPELLING TO CERTAINLY AN
INTERNATIONAL AUDIENCE SOCIAL
ISSUES SUCH AS WOMEN'S RIGHTS,
BUT FOR THAT 10-YEAR-OLD GIRL
WHO YOU MENTIONED, HER FUTURE
LOOKS GRIM, LET'S BE VERY CLEAR
ABOUT THIS.
THERE IS NO IMMEDIATE PLAN FOR
HER TO BE ABLE TO GO TO SCHOOL
AFTER SIXTH GRADE.
WE HEAR ANECDOTALLY STORIES OF
GIRLS DELIBERATELY TRYING TO
FAIL THEIR FIFTH GRADE CLASSES
SO THAT THEY CAN BE ALLOWED TO
REPEAT THE YEAR.
WE KNOW OF MANY CASES OF GIRLS
AND WOMEN WHO ARE COMING
TOGETHER TO SET UP UNDERGROUND
SCHOOLS WHERE GIRLS CAN GO AND
LEARN IN A SORT OF CLANDESTINE
ENVIRONMENT BUT I THINK THAT THE
HEART BREAK FOR SO MANY HERE IS
THAT FOR THE 20 YEARS THAT THE
U.S. AND ITS ALLIES HAD A
PRESENCE IN AFGHANISTAN, WHILE
THAT CERTAINLY WAS A VERY
POLARIZED PRESENCE AND WOULD BE
CATEGORIZED AS AN OCCUPATION BY
MANY, THERE WAS STILL A CHANCE
FOR WOMEN AND GIRLS THAT YOU
COULD DARE TO DREAM, THAT YOU
COULD PARTICIPATE IN SOCIETY.
THOSE DREAMS REALLY HAVE BEEN
ALL BUT SNUFFED OUT NOW.
THE IRC, THE INTERNATIONAL
RESCUE COMMITTEE, WHICH I
MENTIONED BEFORE, HAS SAID THAT
70% OF WOMEN CIVIL SOCIETY
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE BEEN FORCED
TO SHUT DOWN AND COUNTLESS WOMEN
AND GIRLS WHO WERE INVOLVED IN
ACTIVISM, WHO WERE TRYING TO
SPEAK OUT ON BEHALF OF GIRLS
HAVE EITHER BEEN FORCED TO LEAVE
THE COUNTRY OR FORCED TO ABANDON
THAT TYPE OF ACTIVITY BECAUSE IT
CAN POTENTIALLY BE DANGEROUS FOR
THEM AND FOR THEIR FAMILIES.
>> CLARISSA, A COUPLE THINGS
THAT ARE SORT OF RELATED HERE.
I'M CURIOUS IF AND WHY THE
TALIBAN WANTS YOU THERE.
WHAT DO THEY WANT TO SHOW THE
WORLD TODAY ONE YEAR LATER, AND
JUST ONE YEAR LATER, YOU KNOW,
THE AIRPORT, YOU SPENT SO MUCH
TIME AT THE AIRPORT ONE YEAR AGO
AS THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WERE TRYING TO GET OUT.
IS THAT BACK UP, OPERATIONAL AND
OPEN?
>> Reporter: THE AIRPORT IS
OPERATIONAL AGAIN.
WE FLEW A COMMERCIAL AIRLINE IN,
IT'S A PRETTY NORMAL PROCESS,
YOU GO THROUGH PASSPORT CONTROL,
YOU GO THROUGH CUSTOMS, YOU
COLLECT YOUR BAGGAGE, YOU LEAVE
THE AIRPORT.
SOME OF THE WALLS THAT WERE
DOGGED WITH BASICALLY SLOGANS
ABOUT DEMOCRACY AND FREEDOM
DURING THE TIME BEFORE THE
TALIBAN TOOK POWER HAVE NOW BEEN
REPLACED WITH ISLAMIC SLOGANS
AND SYMBOLS, BUT ALSO WE SAW
OUTSIDE THE MINISTRY OF FOREIGN
AFFAIRS YESTERDAY AN INTERESTING
ONE WHICH SAYS THE ISLAMIC
EMIRITE OF AFGHANISTAN WANTS
PEACEFUL AND PROSPEROUS
RELATIONS WITH THE WORLD.
SO FAR AFGHANISTAN UNDER THE
TALIBAN'S LEADERSHIP IS NOT
RECOGNIZED BY A SINGLE COUNTRY
AND WHILE THE TALIBAN DOES SEEM
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THAT PRESENTS
REAL CHALLENGES FOR THEM AND
REAL PROBLEMS FOR THEM,
PARTICULARLY IN TERMS OF
SECURING THE FUNDING AND THE
INVESTMENT AND THE HELP WITH
DEVELOPMENT THAT THEY SO
DESPERATELY NEED, THEY ARE NOT
YET WILLING TO BASICALLY ADAPT
THE MORE PRAGMATIC STANCES THAT
THEY HAD ALWAYS PROMISED TO
THEIR PEOPLE AND TO THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY AND SO
THEY REMAIN RIGID ON THESE AREAS
LIKE FEMALE EDUCATION, DESPITE
NOT EVEN TRYING TO CLAIM THAT
THERE IS ANYTHING IN ISLAM THAT
PREVENTS WOMEN AND GIRLS FROM
ACHIEVING EDUCATION, THEY ARE
STILL VERY UNFLEXIBLE IN TERMS
OF TRYING TO ADAPT THAT MORE
CONCILIATORY PRAGMATIC APPROACH
THAT I JUST REFERRED TO.
I THINK THEY WANT TO SHOW
JOURNALISTS HERE TWO THINGS, AND
THEY'RE PRETTY CATEGORICAL ABOUT
WHAT THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO SEE.
THEY WANT TO SHOW THAT LIFE GOES
ON, THAT THERE IS LAW AND ORDER,
THAT IT IS RELATIVELY SAFE, AND
THEY ALSO WANT TO SHOW THAT THE
POVERTY THAT IS BEING
EXPERIENCED BY PEOPLE HERE IS
BITING AND IT IS REAL AND THEY
WANT TO MAXIMIZE THE AMOUNT OF
PRESSURE THAT'S PUT PARTICULARLY
ON THE U.S. TO UNFREEZE THOSE
FEDERAL RESERVES AND ALLOW FREE
AND UNFETTERED HUMANITARIAN AID
TO ROLL IN.
OBVIOUSLY MANY THINGS, THOUGH,
HAVE MADE THAT A MUCH MORE
COMPLEX PROSPECT THAN PERHAPS
INITIALLY ANTICIPATED.